stefan eichmann à stéphanie grammond
christian duffau bonsoir bonsoir enfin
bon retour qui siègent le soulignait les
gens m'écrivent et qu'avez-vous fait
christian houle avait évincé parce
qu'ils ne pensent pas toujours comme les
pas du tout en vacances
méritées à l'extérieur du pays donc je
vais jeter aérer l'esprit je vous aime
beaucoup et je sais que vous m'aimez
beaucoup bon ben c'est très bon dieu ça
commence bien
assouplissement à
rythmes variables au canada je veux
faire entendre monsieur dubé qui
explique qui peut pas ouvrir tout tout
de suite monsieur qu'est né en alberta
qui lui ouvre pas mal tout tout de suite
et monsieur pas lièvre qui veut être
chef du parti conservateur qui dit
allons-y l'info vous pour retrouver
notre liberté et on revient sûr on a
toujours suivi la santé publique y la
santé publique pour regarder comment ça
évolue puis s'ils recommandent comme mon
année on a tous besoin de passeport dax
nord on est heureux de le faire la même
chose sous les écoles les enfants il
faut être capable de tenir compte de la
situation au nord écoutons la santé
publique jusqu'à maintenant france a été
très payant
nous avons vu les tendances semblables
donc plusieurs pays et juridictions
c'est la raison pour laquelle
l'angleterre l'irlande la norvège la
suède
le danemark et plusieurs autres pays
l'afrique du sud c'est la raison pour
laquelle plusieurs états aux états aux
états unis ont décidé d'éliminer presque
toute leur mesure de santé publique
on
la liberté est en train de gagner mais
où il faut pas arrêter non plus 5 miles
pétition signée ma mission
et on le voit au pont on le voit
ailleurs au canada on le voit je ne
parviens km en français il y a un peu
partout des pressions stéphanie
chouinard je commençais avec vous pour
accélérer
l'apaisement de toutes les mesures
sanitaires
vient au canada les gens c'est plus
facile de se comparer quand c'est au
canada que ça va plus vite là
oui très certainement surtout qu'on a vu
dans les derniers jours plusieurs
premiers ministres provinciaux justement
aller de l'avant avec des annonces de
déconfinement à géométrie variable au
québec on reste plus prudent en alberta
et en saskatchewan
on se débarrasse tout simplement des
passeports vaccinaux s'est déjà fait en
saskatchewan en alberta bon sens même si
le premier ministre camille ne voulais
pas le dire que les pressions à la
frontière sud de la province avec le
blocus avait quelque chose à y voir
c'est fanny grandmont c'est le passeport
vaccinale qui devient le nouveau sujet
c'est l'élément qu'on va regarder avec
plus de soin ici je peux soit entendu
les commerçants un peu plus tôt il y en
a qui disent c'est le moment de le
laisser aller qu'en pensez vous oui
baisse c'est sûr que pour l'instant ça
demeure un outil utile il faut
comprendre que si on donne plus de plus
de derrière et qu'on dit aux gens faites
votre propre votre propre de la
situation apprenez à vivre avec avec le
vih russe il faut aussi quand même qu'il
y ait des outils inde et au tibet c'est
la vaccination est la troisième dose
c'est important et on n'est pas si
avancée que ça malheureusement au québec
il ya encore beaucoup d'ennemis qui
vivent à domicile qui ont pas qui on
prend un taux qui est qui ont pas leur
troisième dose et ça ça pourrait être
assez catastrophique donc le pansement
vaccinale dans toute cette
cette équation l'heure je pense de même
encore pour un certain temps peut-être
pas éternellement mais une solution qui
est avantageuse pour pour protéger les
gens qui vont recommencer graduellement
à les fréquenter davantage de commerces
et christian moi j'ai toujours été
contre le passeport vaccinale vous le
savez je trouve que le lien entre le
passeport vaccinale depuis la
propagation de la cover dépôt prouver
ccpo rigoureux ça va être très très dur
en fait de se disant visée parce que le
canada est l'un des pays au monde en
fait qu'il puisse strictes en matière de
consignes sanitaires et le québec bat
tous les records on est vraiment en
lisent et l'on n'est pas dans la science
finale à la santé exclusivement on est
dans la politique on lit dans
l'idéologie moi je trouve ça désolant ça
me fait beaucoup de peine je partir
qu'avec un long moment j'ai suivi avec
effarement le drame qui est arrivé au
québec autour de noël ça me fait
beaucoup de peine moi de voir ce parce
que la pandémie si pressée mise à prix à
prendre toute la place c'est un
obsessionnel auto de gens me disaient
mauges appeler les gens québec les gens
me disent on n'écoute plus les nouvelles
on n'est plus capable c'est trop c'est
trop hier cheikh ahmed à qui ça qu'à
monter de façon illégale moi je parle
experts s'interrogent au genou changé a
toujours seul je le sais tous les spas
site de son neveu parlez moi c'est hier
je suis arrivé de l'étranger à
l'aréoport c'est kafka s les mesures
qu'on impose aux gens qui reviennent de
l'étranger ça rien à voir avec la
science a rien à voir avec la santé
publique ça coûte une fortune on est
profondément enlisé on est dans
l'idéologie faut en être concernant plus
on est plus en plus divisé le député
libéral joël heit bonne c'est très fort
ce qui le dit on est divisé entre ceux
qui sont encore par deux du virus une
espèce de traumatisme pour nous aussi
tous ceux qui en ont ras le bol qui sont
plus capables moi je fais partie de sal
je voyais les les annonces de monsieur
legault c'est bien beau les programmes
qui sont rien mais à deux points le
passeport center moi là je me
débarrasserait de ça tout de suite
contrairement à stéphanie en tout
respect et le masque le masque pardonnez
moi j'ai été 74 jours dans une société
où le mas est en théorie obligatoire
mais en pratique et pas porter quand je
suis arrivé hier à dorval puis j'ai vu
les gens avec le masque j'ai falloir
juin donne je sais que les gens disent
et banale le mas est pas banal
donc on n'avait pas sorti moi je trouve
que faut s'en sortir mon et plus enragé
sur toutes les autres sociétés je sais
très bien ce sont des plus en lisez
qu'ailleurs les manifestations qui
rend compte du ras-le-bol dont vous
venez de parler christian le pont
ambassadeur la part quand on va entendre
monsieur trudeau parce que on peut pas
laisser ce pont-là ralenti comme ça
pendant très très longtemps on est
content surtout pas envers parler
bon alors que ça s'est enlisée pour
reprendre le mot de christian à ottawa
c'est fanny peu on voit pas très bien on
disait qu'il y avait ce soir des rumeurs
cap à l'est d'ottawa allait mettre
encore plus de pression c'est à voir
mais le pont ambassador on peut être pas
nécessaire ou ralenti comme ça très
longtemps c'est fanny chouinard non
c'est certainement un dangereux d'autant
plus que bon le pain basler c'est l'une
des plaques tournantes évidemment de
l'import export avec les états unis et
ses 70 % de toutes nos exportations qui
s'en vont vers les états unis donc en
termes d'impact sur le pib la fermeture
de la frontière à ce point là c'est tout
à fait névralgique et on commence à
sentir de la pression qui vient non
seulement du milieu du camionnage parce
que là on a des camions avec des denrées
périssables qui sont bloqués depuis des
jours mais aussi des milieux syndicaux
et du patronat du milieu manufacturier
du milieu automobile dans cette région
là qui dépend aussi de ce qui se passe
de part et d'autre du pont pour être
capable d'aller de l'avant avec la
fabrication d automobiles on sait qu'il
ya des jeunes pénurie et donc c'est tout
à fait important c'est même plus
important d'un point de vue purement
économique ce qui se passe à windsor
qu'est ce qui se passe à ottawa ouest et
femmes est grave on a l'impression que
là on va agir plus vite la kawa
évidemment oui mais c'est sûr mais on ne
peut pas dire qu'on ait
la preuve de la police les policiers
d'ottawa ont l'air vraiment dépassé et
puis on peut pas dire non plus que
lequel premier ministre a été six ferme
a pas qu'il n'a pas tenu la ligne dure
mais depuis depuis deux semaines
pratiquement on al impression qu est un
peu aux abonnés absents puis on a vu la
différence là québec d'avoir
des élus qui se sont mobilisés qui ont
dit non et si vous viendrez pas jamais
la capitale et des policiers qui ont été
plus faire ça quand même fonctionné vous
dirais qu'ils avaient il avait une
mémoire il avait vu un peu ce que ça
donnait à tahoua mai mais tout de même
donc oui ça ça va prendre ça va prendre
plus de 2 de rigueur dans l'application
touche au delà à pelham bon on espère
évidemment mais c'est vrai que on peut
pas non plus reste que ces gens là
peuvent pas prendre la population en
attend je conseille termine en demandant
tout ça en faisant toutes sortes de
demandes notamment key le premier
ministre sans ligne alors qu'il ya quand
même été élu par 17 millions de des
lectures il n'y a pas si longtemps donc
ici on a compris votre album je vais pas
tout vous refaire redire mais en même
temps bloqué une vf bloqué un pont il ya
des limites la
romaine faillite de leadership au niveau
fédéral en fait dans l'observation des
lois et sobrement cilss inacceptables ça
ressemble trop de stockton il ya deux
ans quand pendant des semaines en fait
il ya des gens qui me respectait pas la
loi qu'on n'osait pas intervenir comment
les à québec ont été plus efficaces là
dedans donc c'est inacceptable que aussi
aboutir à l'asie ce mouvement leur
présente quelque chose de profond canada
s'est passé mais beau la bien pensante
politico médiatique auquel on a assisté
depuis deux ans par ça a été très fort
au canada rend les jeux tu es gentil les
commentateurs ça mais leur ras-le-bol
profond de la population il s'exprime
aussi par ces camionneurs lol donc c'est
ça le problème un peu c'est que au lieu
du dérapage et lyon manque de leadership
du retournement de mètres de là dedans
c'est évident bon vous parliez de joël
heit oui alesi stéphanie alger je trouve
ça quand même assez intéressant que
ottawa sa demeure en ontario et que
personne ne parle de d'hautefort donc
fort qui ont manqué les deux dernières
rencontres de la table de concertation
et qui n'est pas allé à ottawa depuis le
début de la manifestation à ottawa c'est
quand même fondamentalement ça demeure
sa responsabilité les municipalités sont
les créatures des provinces et on peut
certainement blanc mais le fédéral de ne
pas avoir réagi assez vite mais il
demeure que dog pound démontre un très
gros manque de leadership actuellement
sur ce qui se passe à ottawa c'est comme
si ottawa n'était pas non thériault dans
son esprit comme si tu es un territoire
district fédéral comme washington bon
hockey joël lightbourne vous en avez
parlé christian hier qui a dit je ne
suis pas d'accord avec le ton qu'emploie
mon premier ministre avec le côté
de vouloir marquer des points politiques
dans une joute politique sur la
vaccination
je ne suis pas d'accord sur la
vaccination obligatoire nécessairement
les employés fédéraux ni des camionneurs
donc joie de l'acba ornière on l'a
entendu là aujourd'hui marc aurèle
fortin collègues députés marc aurèle
fortin
ivre bien dans le comté de
marc-aurèle-fortin qui a dit je suis
totalement d'accord avec live band donc
tour de table je conseille vous
christian rapidement ça veut dire que
cette idée qu'on adopte peut-être fait
trop elle elle n'appartient pas
uniquement des gens d'extrême droite qui
veulent qu'ils veulent rien savoir de
rien c'est très fort en fait la
déclaration de paul diamond ça fait le
tour du canada le suppôt du strict
s'intéressent pas juste les francophones
parce que c'est profond puits y des
choses qui sont très très vrai
l'accusation qu'il porte à l'égard de
monsieur trudeau est très dur mais les
jeux trudeau vraiment diviser la
population québécoise sur ce terrain
gelé alors se retrouve dans une société
qui est profondément divisé parce que
leur ras le bol à l'égard des mesures
internes y est très fort mais à mon avis
va monter alors je me suis convaincu que
ça va être encore plus fort mais une
partie de la population qui est encore
traumatisé par la pandémie puis en veut
aux non vaccinés on est confronté à ces
messieurs l'allemand chapeau était pas
facile de faire c'est fait tu vois ça
fait du bien d'avoir un jeune policier
élégant intelligent et profond qui dit
des choses qu'on voulait tout sans
battre comme moi je voulais reprendre 6
le général que vous vouliez très bien
stéphanie grammond qu'est ce que sarah
parce que si on a deux trois quatre cinq
là ça commence est une fissure plus
importante au sein du caucus libéral
c'est quand même intéressant parce que
on est plus habitué de voir les
déchirements qui est qui qui s'en prend
au parti conservateur
mais les libéraux en général tout se
pensent les discussions se passent
davantage plus en famille est las de
voir comme cela là les fissures qui
commence à craquer dans la peinture
c'est quand même symptomatique peut-être
justement d'une division et à
l'intérieur même du pays et c'est vrai
on le voyait un sondage léger encore
tout récemment qui dit que les
pratiquement le tiers de la population
qui qui se dit quand même en accord avec
les propos qui sont tenus le par les
manifestants les camionneurs donc cessé
quand même et c'est quand même
significatif parce que c'est est-ce que
ça va s'étioler au fur et à mesure la
queue
comme les magistrats enseignants vont
devenir plus grand pour lui pour les
gens qui qui mâche du côté des gens qui
sont victimes des manifestants puis en
même temps faut bien dire les mesures
sanitaires
se relâche le québec un peu partout en
alberta donc les manifestants ils sont
un peu rattrapé par par ce qui se passe
par le relâchement des mesures donc plus
ça va aller moins leurs revendications
vont être justifié ces fins des
cheminots je lui posais la question
camionneurs français vous voulez quoi
parce que là où j'arrivais à mama
votre album arrive un moment où on ouvre
les sociétés là en france notamment aux
états unis partout
oui tout à fait et donc c'est ça
comporte un risque ce timing parce que
dans un sens ça peut être interprété par
les chefs de l'occupation à ottawa comme
comme une victoire alors que bon on peut
dire pendant toute la journée était 3h30
on va avoir raison de me [ __ ] dans la
journée ça veut pas dire que l'on est la
cause de l'autre effectivement on savait
que bon suivant les dernières vagues
avec la fin de l'hiver il y avait des
bonnes chances pour commencent à valoir
chez les mesures sanitaires puis vous et
vous lac bande stéphanie chouinard est
ce qu'il ya un effet plus profond où
vous croyez ou jeter un coup de tonnerre
un coup de dés classes en jeu de boules
mais c'est intéressant qu'on voit sont
au canada comme un coup de tonnerre il
faut savoir que de façon comparé la
politique parlementaire au canada est
extrêmement discipliné et salaire de
tonnerre mais ce qui se passe au canada
actuellement dans un autre pays comme la
grande bretagne ça serait la routine
quotidienne qu'on entendait un membre du
caucus dit désolé je suis pas d'accord
avec mon chef ou avec ma chef sur cet
enjeu là ça ne ferait pas les nouvelles
parce que ça se passe à tous les jours
donc quelque chose de sain est ce que ça
puisse se passer quand même ouais tout à
fait tout à fait moi je pense que c'est
un bon signe que je lis que les députés
se se donne cette ce droit-là de dire
publiquement mais écoutez je fais partie
de ce groupe là j'ai toujours confiance
en mon gouvernement mais je suis pas
nécessairement d'accord avec 100% de
christiane easy way jeu j'espère être
pessimiste mais je suis pas sûr que ce
que dit stéphanie ramon tout à l'heure
que le fait que l'eau les mesures
sanitaires vont s'atténuer ça se réalise
parce que moi je crois vraiment que
c'est profondément incrustée puis
contexte peut changer puis pas avoir d
augmentation des hospitalisations
deux exemples de ce on ne part le moment
donné d'un passeport center qui
tiendrait compte des troisièmes de la
troisième dose ça c'est pas une
réflexion qui vont vers le sens de
l'abolition des mesures du passeport
centers c'est ça veut dire grand cho et
risks arides comme on dit sont très
faibles et dans le jardin des halles
peut-être que je le cite mal mais on
faisait dire à monsieur karl weiss qu il
faudrait peut-être s'habituer aux
masques en permanence donc moi j'espère
me tromper les trop pessimiste mais moi
j'y crois que c'est parfois de maîtrise
pour envoyer ailleurs c'est pire
qu'ailleurs ils vont s intéresse vous ré
habite suis romaric et b6 et vous
réhabituer aux masques il ya des
endroits où beaucoup de gens sont quand
je suis parti en novembre pour venir ici
au studio 3 ou qu'elle adore demandait
pas le passeport sanitaires tout à
l'heure mais le mode
beaucoup d'entreprises mené en effet le
passeport est hélas si vous allez faire
des courses dans une grande surface je
vous annonce que vous avez besoin votre
passeport merci à vous trois intéressant
merci au revoir en forme pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici r d